[Música]
hablamos de salud del directo américa de
france al 24 está conmigo por supuesto
más romeros a la mar bienvenida feliz
mañana de miércoles vamos a empezar en
eeuu porque el gobierno de yubá ya
propuso disminuir la cantidad de
nicotina en los cigarrillos le pregunto
el objetivo bueno sea raúl o pues
efectivamente la red resulta que una de
las propuestas de bailén en términos de
salud de reducir las muertes por cáncer
un 25 por ciento pues en 25 perdón un 50
por ciento en 25 años entonces una de
las propuestas que está impulsando desde
está enfocada en el tabaco el tabaco es
uno de los principales causantes de
cáncer en estados unidos y además
considera que en ese país y también en
el mundo es una de las principales
causas de muertes evitables es decir de
muertes que se podrían prevenir en total
480 mil cada año que son además
prematuras el objetivo de reducir la
nicotina consiste en hacerla me hacen
los cigarrillos pues menos adictivos y
hacer así que también pues los fumadores
o si alguien prueba el tabaco no se
conviertan en fumadores habituales las
entidades de salud de estadounidenses
estiman que podrían evitarse así pues
que 33 millones de fumadores ocasionales
a fumadores regulares además recordemos
que la nicotina no es lo que produce
cáncer la nicotina es lo que hace que se
haya adicción al tabaco y hablando del
cáncer mal entonces le pregunto cuáles
son los compuestos que están comprobados
digamos y estudiados que realmente
producen cáncer sí pues vamos a repasar
un poco que contiene un cigarrillo por
si hablamos mucho de esta relación entre
las enfermedades y el tabaco pero pocas
veces la diseccionamos se considera que
hay de centenares de compuestos químicos
hasta miles de compuestos químicos en el
tabaco pero de ellos una unos 70
aproximadamente que son cancerígenos o
tóxicos empezando además desde la planta
del tabaco no que es la que contiene la
nicotina pero es que además también
puede contener cambio por ejemplo plomo
dos elementos tóxicos que se pueden
encontrar en la tierra donde crece sobre
todo en grandes cantidades no no en
pequeñas cantidades y que se liberan
pues al fumar el cigarrillo después
cuando se manufacturan también qué más
tenemos por ejemplo la momia que se
añade para que pues
se acelere la manera en que absorbemos
la nicotina eso también hace que pues
ayude a la adicción y también por
ejemplo estas nitrosaminas que son unos
componentes que se hacen pues en los
procesos de curar y de secar el tabaco
de forma natural que también son
cancerígenas además también se añaden
azúcares para hacer más apetitoso el
producto que pueden convertirse en
cancerígenos cuando pues se entra en
combustión el cigarrillo por último al
fumar importante también recordar que lo
que fumamos y lo que se libera en el
tabaco puede afectar a otras personas
que inhalen ese humo hay monóxido de
carbono que es un contaminante por
ejemplo es lo que sale de los tubos de
escape del coche benceno que es se
obtiene de hecho del alquitrán y por
ejemplo la acetona que es lo que usamos
para sacar el esmalte de uñas importante
decir que no es que sea cancerígeno en
este caso pero si es tóxico en grandes
cantidades claro y por supuesto usted ve
todos los componentes de ahí y hamás uno
iría al mercado a comprarlo a comer de
entonces uno se lo fuma y pues
cambiamos de tema podemos hablar de la
habilidad del mono porque tenemos que
empezar a llamarla de otra forma le
pregunto pues todavía no pero depende de
la organización mundial de la salud de
la salud que se la esté lo está
planteando de hecho ha recibido
organizaciones de científicos que le han
hecho estas peticiones para cambiar en
base a de que consideran que el nombre
de vino' la del mono puede ser
discriminatorio hay varios argumentos
empezando por las dos variantes que se
considera que existen de viloria del
mono son como las ramas se llaman claros
de hecho y se conocen dos se identifican
como la variante de áfrica occidental y
la variante congo entonces hace tiempo
por ejemplo que la organización mundial
de la salud recomienda que las
enfermedades no se nombren pues por los
lugares donde se han encontrado por la
estigmatización que eso podría generar
que también piden que no se nombre con
nombres de animales y eso nos lleva la
parte del mono no de la viruela del mono
de hecho es poco acertado porque en el
reservorio no es los monos sino se
considera que son otras otros roedores
otros tipos de animales y además pues
hay otros científicos que han apuntado
que puede ser estigmatizador por todo el
continente africano porque además pues
ese término de mono ha sido muchas veces
usado de forma denigrante para la
comunidad pues tanto de áfrica como las
comunidades afro en el resto del mundo
claro mar y digamos es quien decide cómo
se nombran estas enfermedades hay como
un departamento aquí para decir esta
enfermedad se llama tal y cual pues
digamos que inicialmente no no se nombra
a quienes la descubrían pero con el
tiempo se ha intentado regular ahora de
hecho si hay un comité internacional de
la taxonomía de los virus que eso pues
se encarga solo de los virus no de las
enfermedades de los virus para
nombrarlos y luego también hay una
clasificación internacional de
enfermedades y la ms que se encarga de
nombrar el resto de las enfermedades
vamos a repasar una serie de ejemplos
para ver pues cómo ha funcionado a lo
largo también de los últimos años por
ejemplo el ejemplo del ébola eso fue
nombrado por quienes lo descubrieron y
le pusieron el nombre del río que pasa
por uno de los pueblos donde se aisló el
virus por primera vez entonces allí
contraviniendo esas recomendaciones que
existen actualmente luego con el sida
por ejemplo recordemos que el vih y el
sida tanto el virus como la enfermedad
llegaron a llamarse el cáncer de las
personas gays
4 h porque lo contraria no homosexuales
hemofílicos haitianos y consumidores de
heroína nombres totalmente
estigmatizantes y discriminatorios hasta
que en eeuu decidieron nombrarlo pues el
síndrome de la inmunodeficiencia
adquirida que es un hombre puramente
descriptivo y es el que ha quedado hasta
ahora después también en 2013 hubo
críticas por el meros no de las
enfermedades respiratorias porque viene
de mi del isc de medio oriente y ahí
también se contravenía esa decisión o
esas recomendaciones de la ms de no
nombrar las de así pero igualmente pues
este comité de la taxonomía de virus
pues lo llamó así y un último ejemplo lo
que hemos visto con el commit 19no una
nomenclatura que decidió la organización
mundial de la salud es una abreviación
del nombre de la enfermedad y que
también pues se tomó rápidamente esta
decisión para evitar que siguiera
llamándose el virus de wuhan o la virus
china por ejemplo etcétera entonces
bueno recordar que como se nombran las
cosas importan nombrarlas hacen que
exista y pues así seguimos hoy en día
vamos a ver entonces si cambia el nombre
de estas enfermedades y para que no se
creen estigmatización es anormal
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información nosotros pasamos a
saludar